[MUSIC PLAYING]
I work in research, helping to
develop the next generation of
diesel engines.
We will follow these down
the production line.
They'll burn less fuel, produce
fewer emissions, and
have greater power densities,
just as these did for their
predecessors.
But research and development
doesn't happen in isolation.
Anything we develop in the test
lab has to be something
we can build down the production
line here.
Let me give you an example
of how technology and
manufacturing move together.
Within the engine, you can just
about see the top of six
injectors, one for
each cylinder--
much like this.
The fuel enters the injector
here at about 200 megapascals.
That's about the same pressure
as 5,000 two tonne elephants
standing on top of you.
It's then actuated on the
solenoid up here, which allows
the fuel to enter the cylinder
through six holes, which are
really tiny-- about the
size of a human hair.
This combined with the high
pressure means the fuel enters
the cylinder as a really
fine mist.
This means the fuel burns more
efficiently, and therefore, we
produce less emissions.
But with the small hole and high
pressures, there's really
tight tolerances within the
injector, so the fuel entering
it has to be free of debris.
Which, on the final engine,
isn't an issue, as we have a
system of filters
to remove it.
But first, we have to
build the engine.
We're getting ready to go
into the clean room.
Not something you'd expect to
find in a diesel engine
factory, but this facility
is crucial.
This room is pressurised such
that there is no flow of air
from the outside other
than through the
filtration and scrubbers.
They ensure that there is no
more than 30,000 particles
above five micron per
cubic metre of air.
That may sound like a lot, but
an office environment has up
to 35 million.
So in here, we can as
confidently assemble the fuel
system knowing we're not
introducing any contaminants.
The point to this?
To design efficient engines,
we need new technology.
But there's no point if
we can't build it.
This clean room is a good
example of how a manufacturing
facility is allowing us to make
better design decisions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]